this morning on a special edition of the
dish
Jorge Vallejo is Mexico City restaurant
Quinta Neil has been a dining
destination named one of the 40 best in
the world because of the pandemic Quinto
neil is now offering baskets of produce
paired with virtual cooking classes
instead of dinner service last summer I
got a chance to look at Vallejo and his
new restaurant honoring Mayan culture on
a visit to the Yucatan Peninsula in the
heart of Mexico on this lush plantation
is we're picking some beautiful flowers
chef Jorge Vallejo tends to his garden
flower and his harvest it all supplies
the bounty of his new restaurant it XI
which means corn in Mayan it's the story
we want to tell to the people one of the
spinal cords of the Mexican gastronomy
or the Mexican culture it's about corn
so for me is a very I would say
democratic ingredient because it's not
about the monetary value it's all about
the flavor the the pureness of the
ingredient and that's why we want us to
say we are currently his mission to
distinguish a Mayan eating experience by
preparing humble ingredients with modern
Flair and cook it from you know only
from one side like escolar a buttery
fish from the Gulf of Mexico prison when
I gave it it takes these flavors what
are the main main life but look at you
just digging it up do you feel there's
no penis of the of the fish this is
really good Jorge it's delicious
I hope you enjoyed equally as delicious
the beauty of this setting it Sheen
anchors chablis a luxury resort built in
the grounds of an old Hacienda his
restaurants have become a retreat for
global visitors and Vallejo says
recently have been a bridge to Mexico's
northern neighbor the US I will say
ninety percent of the people that comes
into the restaurant are not Mexicans
actually we had to give English lessons
to our waiters because probably out of
that 90 percent 60 percent of the people
are Americans extreme is 45 minutes from
Merida the Yucatan capital but it feels
like a place from another time culture
it is it's all about Mayan culture the
people still know these days they are
very proud about their culture they're
very proud about being Mayans they are
actually the ones that keep the
tradition they're the ones that keep the
flavors are the ones that keep the keep
the environment Mexico is not one thing
if you go to Oaxaca they have their own
traditions they their own flavors even
they their own past his own food story
started early instead of toys for
Christmas I can eat chicken and rice
every day I have a three year old
daughter probably the kids are the most
wise people in the world because they
live now the present for me being a cook
or serving people it's about that that
kitchen obsessed kid who had trouble
concentrating in school decided to give
cooking a try I was just in my own world
I was lucky enough to find something
that I can lose myself which is cooking
but extreme also quenches the thirst for
another ancient tradition tequila was
born in Mexico Louise Ronson and Luis
Alberto Flores Muyo are experts in
tequila you don't need to pour that much
Akim has the largest tequila collection
in the world
3800 bottle strong if you want to try
our Mexican dish would not be complete
fire fire without a lesson in the proper
etiquette of tequila sipping because
tequila like the cuisine here in this
pocket of paradise is to be savored for
chef Alejo the way to honor his Mexican
heritage is to bring that Mayan cuisine
to the world stage and that's what we
want to showcase here in the in the
restaurant the pureness of the
ingredients but how can really works in
a luxury audience
mission accomplished because King
Tennille
has been rated one of the top
restaurants in the world know I'm filled
you know very proud about what we
achieved already and just as I told you
I'm still learning I'm still like wanted
to to do more so for me of course is Sam
as you're saying mission accomplished
but still not finished let me tell you
something I was never shy about Mexican
food even less so with mezcal right now
bring it on group trip by the way guys
group trip as soon as the quarantine is
over it's all I'm gonna say we are
mission mission mezcal all right